this morning marks a new milestone for
legal marijuana Massachusetts is now the
first state on the East Coast to allow
recreational marijuana sales starting
today tens of millions of adult
consumers including those in New York
City are within a three-hour drive to a
pot shop
Tony de copal is in Northampton
Massachusetts outside one of the two
stores opening in the state today Tony
good morning
good morning well it is cold it is wet
it is rainy and marijuana is still very
much illegal at a federal level but take
a look at that those people have been
building in that line since around
midnight they're hoping to make some of
the first purchases in this state since
a hundred years ago when marijuana was
pro a prohibited and you will never
guess who the very first person is in
line it's another morning of long lines
I wanted to be the first person to buy
weed east of the Mississippi for a drug
that's come a long way
I've been waiting 38 years for this in
first in line
David Norco it's the mayor of
Northampton is it only a symbolic
purchase or will it be consumed as well
actually people have asked me about that
and you know I am actually going to
probably preserve it and display it
because it is historically significant
Massachusetts is the seventh state to
open retail marijuana shops but the
first to open them east of the
Mississippi and it comes as the cannabis
industry celebrates a series of new
highs earlier this month Michigan became
the first Midwestern state to approve
recreational cannabis joining ten other
states and Washington DC and in October
our neighbors to the north Canada became
the first major world economy to
legalize recreational marijuana but the
steady march of marijuana legalization
has dr. Sharon levy concerned she runs
the adolescent substance use and
addiction program at Boston Children's
Hospital instead of saying well we'll
assume these things are safe until
they're proven harmful maybe we should
be saying these things might be harmful
until they're proven safe I don't think
that that's something we've done a very
good job with we've been preparing for
for adult use cells for many many months
now Amanda Rosa tano is the director of
operational compliance for New England
treatment access or Neda which as of
today sells a range of cannabis products
including pre-rolled joints loose buds
oils and edibles to anyone over the age
of 21 do you think dependence could be
an issue for anybody so I mean I think
dependence could be an issue just like
dependence could be an issue when it
comes to ice cream we will advocate
using moderation educate people about
cannabis under Massachusetts law retail
shops can sell each customer no more
than an ounce of flour or 20 servings of
edibles both in child resistant
packaging for now those restrictions and
others are good enough for mayor
Norquist
there has been marijuana use going on in
the Commonwealth of Massachusetts for a
long long time what's changing is it's
now being regulated it's now being
tested it's now being strictly monitored
that's really the major change that's
happening and speaking of change voters
here in Massachusetts actually legalize
marijuana more than two years ago but it
took that long for regulations to be put
in place and for shops like this to meet
those regulations still the pace of
change can't be surprising to some
people my own father
believe it or not stood federal trial
for marijuana smuggling in this very
state today he feels vindicated but he
can't really handle this new stuff gale
he says it's too strong mr. dick COPO
ahead of his time hey Tony I love the
question to merit narco it's great 9 by
the way for the mayor when you said do
you plan to use it or it is just for
saving he seemed to go humming a homina
homina and then say oh yeah I'm gonna
save it very clever way to duck a key
question no I thought so too
thank you Tony to Coco always good to
see you vindication for your dad say hi
from us anybody heading to Massachusetts
today there's nothing for the holidays
no my family from Massachusetts coming
oh yeah that's right